hello welcome to my Josie block by the
sea hello welcome to Jersey this is me
in a few hours time from where you last
just saw me
I tried filming this on the beach but it
was really really really windy and you
couldn't hear anything I said I am here
at Josie because well 7 years old my mum
bought me a book she brought me this
exact book in fact this is my family and
other animals by gel doll and I've been
on the record saying this is my favorite
book of all times and she bought it's me
here in Jersey and more specifically
here which is what's now called doll
needs to be called Jersey Z and this
book it's all about the childhood of
Gerald doll and he grew up to be a
naturalist and the conservationist and
founded JZ Zoo which was renamed in his
honor what Darryl has now become is a
conservation charity which is global in
its reach and almost unmatched in its
ambition and what it does is it saves
species from extinction I you might
remember that I actually made a project
for awesome video about this little
while back and it just so happened that
the people at Durrell saw this I've got
in contact with me and asked if I'd like
to make some videos for them so
naturally I say yes because this has
been a childhood passion of mine ever
since I've read this book I've been
hooked on both the books that Gerald I
wrote and the message that the books
convey so don't look very very kindly
agreed to put me up in their hostel
which is where I am right now and it's a
chance for me to go behind the scenes
and make some really really exciting
videos but all that pass the time and
take over where he is waxing lyrical
about how simple ARS Bay is his happy
place more specifically than the bay
just the bay though this is my space
this is a restaurant that's actually
called the wayside capper thing but we
used to come here every single time and
we call it Hagrid's because the portion
sizes here are just massive see what I
mean and
it's like our favorite restaurant in the
entire world so right now I'm so happy
that's it son warm those pasty legs so I
start moving at dural tomorrow I just
arrived here I didn't like land
assault on the island I just flew in but
I've got this afternoon to basically go
to other places that I went when I was a
kid so simple as this photo just had
lunch and there's a few things on this
beach actually we're going to show you
so I have the other doll Japan just like
you
oh I should probably say actually thanks
very much to cloudy on Twitter no sorry
thanks very much to Claudio on Twitter
who I can't do Jack Saxon I'm sorry Jake
but Claudio and Jake on Twitter
recommended that I get a canon g7x for
vlogging purposes which is what I'm
doing right now I've got to say it's a
pretty great recommendation it's done
everything I've asked of it this is now
gonna be a workhorse in my shade in my
camera fleet
so yeah thank you very much cloudy on
Jake it's a really really good
recommendation so one thing that you'll
find if you travel pretty much anywhere
in the world is fishermen a uniformly
quite a god-fearing bunch of people when
you can kind of understand you know
you're in this tiny craft on the sea a
batter on my force is completely going
to comprehension and it's nice to think
or feel that you have somebody upstairs
who's looking after you and sober Lars
is no different so super lads used to be
a really big fishing village and so this
behind me is the fisherman's Chapel
it's rather special because while there
is a really nice in fact really by the
lovely parish church which dates back to
at least the 13th century and it's gotta
be said is actually probably the most
peaceful Chapel I've ever been in
there's something even more special just
here so this is the fisherman's Chapel
and what the parish church has existed
for well since about 1200 they think
there's evidence that this building has
been here for at least a thousand years
and the most remarkable thing about it
is these paintings behind me so these
were wall paintings which to various
scenes from the Bible that were
completed about thirteen hundreds and
they represent a really distinctive
medieval style art which you really
rarely see in in wall paintings like
this and over time they've been worn
away almost completely but you get this
sense of what they would have looked
like I mean admittedly I'm not a
religious person I've talked about this
in videos before but being here in this
Chapel especially when I'm alone I've
been this is
this is probably where I come closest to
feeling a real connection to a higher
being still quiet place resonating with
history I absolutely love this chapel
this is one of my favorite things about
Jersey and this pain so I hope you don't
mind me taking you here
I'm very sorry to disappoint any of you
who expect to see me in a skimpy
two-piece bikini sunday for a bit I am
gonna have to go to the door and make
sure that everything set up but if
you're filming tomorrow so sorry Falzon
you're expecting about life's full of
disappointments so case you didn't know
jay-z's famous for its ice cream come on
I mean if you're here you gonna you
gonna do it bollocks to the diet so
while I'm sat here waiting for a bus I
thought I'd tell you a little bit more
about what I am doing here I'm sorry but
I have to keep looking up like here
that's because there's a screen and I'm
not used to be able to see myself in the
viewfinder so I'm working with Daryl to
put the spotlight on three of their
projects we're gonna be looking at their
work with Livingston fruit bats which
are these huge gray big bats some of the
biggest in the world with wings bats
about five feet and basically putting a
spotlight on their habitat in Doral
which is a really amazing polytunnel and
there are a lot them are pregnant at the
moment so hopefully we're going we're
really lucky they also get pregnant at
birth on camera which would be a well
first so we're taking a fix on that the
second project is we are looking at
tamarind so tamarins these little tiny
monkeys which come from South America
from Brazil and they're all is might be
unique in the world because they
actually allow their tamarins they some
of them to roam free in the park it's a
it's a wooded park and gangs of tamarins
just just crawling around so I'm going
to spend the day chasing them which
would be really really fun
and then lastly they are currently
working on a conservation
so those are three projects we're
talking to making videos for for their
channel in addition to those videos
there's going to be these travel vlogs
and there's also going to be some vlogs
on my channel where we'll get me
answering some questions and just
throwing the spotlight really and what
on what they're doing at there all
because but Federal's youtube channel
that's going to be videos which detail
the work they do for their stakeholders
people that donate whereas the videos to
my channel I want to basically showcase
what they will do and try and get new
people involved with them rather than
reassuring current don't have donors
that their funds are being well used so
I really really hope you enjoy the
videos coming out of this there's gonna
be a lot I think so stay tuned
so I'm currently just in haliotis dying
capital for a bus transfer
I love it I love this place I love this
weather video work
everything's coming up millhouse
and we're here
so I've arrived here in the hostel I've
got a really nice room at the very top
with the I don't know why I'm showing
you around this is gonna be my base of
operations for the next few days this
hostel I stayed here once before is so
cool so in down in the kitchen for
example they have posters about why
vegetarianism is great for the
environment which is why I'm vegetarian
they have an entire scientific library
downstairs they actually have a room
which is full of biological and
zoological journals they have a lounge
kitchen and all the rooms are named
after animals which are forced to
extinction by mankind so there's there's
this constant subtext constant
background of why this place exists it's
incredibly peaceful here it kind of
feels like it's always a little bit um
not how it's and like but it almost just
feels like very so tranquil it so it's
it's like Elysium or something I don't
know not the typical notion of heaven
but like somewhere where you're at rest
and it just employees everything that
you like although admittedly I'm
currently phone is out of window and I
don't have any curtains so I am
anticipating oh I'm going to be working
out tomorrow morning by Gibbons that
sentence is so weird
it was an extra game of trainings it
turns out so the boy what about
childhood here is just came in a tossed
tie my feeling was going